let's do a comparison between open end
and closed and mutual funds so this is
going to be the open end scenario and
over here in purple i will do the closed
end scenario
so in an open end scenario if i think
that i'm a good investor i might go to
some people and say okay i'm going to
give you i'm going to sell you some
shares and with the money i get i will
invest it and so let's say initially and
i'm going to use really low numbers and
unusually low numbers just to make the
diagramming a little bit easier let's
say i go to four friends and i get a
dollar from each of them
normally it'd be more like four million
friends but hopefully this will give you
the general idea
so here are all the shares
so there's four shares and i get a
dollar from each of them i get a dollar
from each of them so i am able to raise
i am able to raise
four
dollars and we would call right here
especially if the four dollars is all
sitting in cash this four dollars is the
net asset value
the net asset value of the fund now why
do i go through the trouble of doing
this well i as the manager can take a
management fee off of the net asset
value so i might take let's say i take
one percent for myself
annually one percent annually and that's
what i use for my office space and to
pay my own salary and to pay the junior
analyst salaries etc etc
now this is the key point to an
open-ended fund or an open end fund i
should say let's say a fifth person
comes along and says hey look i also
want to participate in your fund well
you if you're running an open-ended fund
you can say okay sure well right now our
net asset value per share our net asset
value is four dollars we have four
shares so our nav per share is one
dollar
so it's a one dollar let me write down
here one dollar
nav
nav per share
so if you give me another dollar i can
create another share for you so what i
would do then is i would create another
share for you you would give me your
dollar and now the net asset value of
the fund is no longer four dollars i had
four dollars but you just gave me a
dollar the net asset value is now five
dollars and notice the net asset value
per share has not changed five dollars
we have five shares now let's say i'm
able to manage this quite well
and we go to a future state where i've
been able to turn the five dollars even
after taking out my fees etc etc i'm
able to turn that into ten dollars
i'm able to turn that into ten dollars
so this is the ten dollars right over
here i've invested it well in stocks
so the net asset value is now ten
dollars i still only have five shares i
still only have five shares let me draw
the five shares here
so this is one
two
three
four five and now what is the net asset
value per share we have a ten dollar net
asset value and i have five shares 10
divided by five we now have a
we now have a two dollar nav
nav per share so let's say the person
who happened to own
this share down here says okay this is
great you've been a great fund manager
but i now need my two dollars i need it
to go i don't know buy a soda or
something and so this is the other key
of an open-ended fund open end fund if
this investor the person who has the
share wants to
get their cash back they essentially
give it back to the fund manager the
fund manager has to come up maybe sell
some assets so two dollars worth of
assets so the fund manager has to take
this two dollars right over here the
fund manager has to take this two
dollars so
it will and return it to the person who
owned the share so the two dollars will
go to that person who owned the share
and then the share will be canceled and
then this share will be cancelled and so
what had just happened well now the nav
so let me show all of this stuff down
here has disappeared has now disappeared
now the nav is eight dollars because we
just had to give eight dolla two dollars
to that person who wanted to redeem
their share
now it is
eight dollars and there's four shares so
we still have a two dollars net asset
value per share so the main key idea
here with this open end fund
is if you want to buy into the fund you
transact essentially with the fund
managers and they'll create a share for
you and they will take your they will
take your money if you want to redeem
your shares if you want to get your cash
back once again you transact with the
fund managers you say hey okay you claim
it's a two dollar nav per share well i
want my two dollars for my share back
and they will give it back to you the
nav will shrink and the share base the
number of shares will shrink in a closed
end in a closed end fund you don't
transact in that way with the fund
managers it can start off very similarly
so let's do it in a very similar way
so let's say
in a very similar way when you create
your closed end fund
you go to four investors who each give
you a dollar so let me draw that
four investors who each
give you
each give you a dollar so you have a
four dollar you have a four dollar nav
four dollar net asset value
now let's go through the same scenario
let's say a fifth person says hey look
and similarly the way you pay your bills
is you take a management fee maybe it is
one percent
one percent
annually on the nav there's different
ways that you might structure a fee
structure but let's to to show the the
commonalities let's do it the exact same
way but let's say that fifth person
comes along says hey i really really
want to buy into this fund you've
created well in a closed end fund once
you've done your initial issuance of
shares you aren't going to create more
shares like this or at least you're not
going to do it in a typical way a open
end mutual fund can do this on a daily
basis a closed and mutual fund typically
will not create new shares so this this
is the fixed pool of shares that it has
so if the fifth person wants to come in
and buy into it they are essentially
going to have to go to one of the people
who already own shares and buy it from
them so in a closed end mutual fund the
shares you don't buy and sell with the
fund managers once it's created you then
trade these shares you trade the shares
on a market and it could be the new york
stock exchange or the nasdaq or anything
else trade
on a
trade on a market and the the price per
share on that market often will actually
usually does diverge from the net asset
value per share in this scenario the way
i've constructed it we have a one dollar
one dollar net asset value per share but
let's say people are feeling really
really good about this fund manager's
ability to invest some money so that
share the share that has a one dollar
net asset value might trade above one
dollar maybe the person said like that
person's so desperate like i want to pay
a dollar 25 for a share like that so it
might trade at let's say
1.25 because there's so much demand to
get into this fund and so you could have
a market price per share that diverges
from the nav per share and in this case
when the market price is above the nav
per share we would say that it is
trading at a
it is trading at a premium
we could think of another scenario maybe
more people aren't buying into the share
maybe the person who maybe the person
who has this share right over here is
has second thoughts learned new things
about the fund manager that makes them a
little queasy so they're desperate to
get out and so when they trade on the
market when they trade on the market
they they're they just willing to get
anything that they can get and so let's
say they sell
they sell for
80 cents per share so
it's 80 cents
per share
so in this situation when the market
price has been or the when the share has
been traded for
less than the net asset value per share
we say it has been traded at a discount
so traded
traded at i'll just use the at symbol
traded at a
traded at a discount now you might be
saying hey wait sal
i understand with an open end fund if
the fund grows i can redeem my shares
the shares get cancelled i get the money
back in this scenario if i'm not
transacting with the fund itself how do
i actually make money
well what the fund manager can do and
this is actually very close to what a
typical publicly traded corporation will
do is as they earn money in this fund
they can dividend it they can dividend
it out to the actual shareholders so
let's imagine a scenario maybe this
closed end mutual fund maybe it's doing
maybe it buys a bunch of assets the
assets grow do well so we'll think about
the positive scenario here and once
again let's say that those four dollars
grow to eight dollars those four dollars
grow to eight dollars
so we have an eight dollar nav
eight dollar
nav
and we still have four shares that
hasn't changed
so we still have four shares let me draw
the four shares
we now have a two dollar nav per share
so we now have a two dollar two dollar
nav
per share
and these shares could be trading at any
price it could be trading at 2.50 it
could be trading at a dollar if it's
trading at 2.50 it's trading at a
premium to its nav per share if it's
trading at 1.50 now it's trading at a
discount to its nav per share and let's
say the fund managers right here they
want to start dividending to some things
out so what they can do is maybe all of
this eight dollars in assets maybe it's
stocks or something else the fund
manager
the fund manager can sell some of them
they can send sell some of them let's
say they sell
i don't know let's say they sell four
dollars worth of it so then it turns
into it's still a eight dollar nav but
let's say it's four dollars in cash
four dollars in cash and let's say it's
four dollars in stocks four dollars in
stocks and maybe they'll actually want
to dividend out this four dollars in
cash so they give everyone they give
everyone a one dollar per share
a one dollar per share dividend
and this is very similar to what what a
publicly traded company might actually
do or any company when they issue a
dividend so act after that has happened
the nav for this company is now or for
this i should say closed end fund which
is set up usually as some type of a
corporation the nav is now four dollars
because we've given back four dollars in
cash four dollar nav we still have those
same four shares one two three four and
so our nav per share is one dollar so we
have a one dollar
one dollar
nav
per share and you might say oh wait this
doesn't sound so good i had 2 nav per
share for before now i only have a 1 nav
per share what you need to remember is
each of these shareholders just got a
dollar so they now have a share that has
a 1 nav per share and they got and they
got another dollar so they still
essentially got
by holding this they have two dollars
assuming they were there when the
dividend was actually issued
so what are the main advantages
disadvantages
well in a closed and in an open-end fund
because at any on any given day
investors can redeem more shares the
closed and the open-end fund i should
say has to keep some money has to keep
some money in cash for the redemptions
that might occur on that day in a
closed-end fund there's a little bit
more flexibility and also the closed-end
fund manager doesn't have to worry as
much about well hey maybe people are
going to take my all the capital away
and i'm going to have to sell a bunch of
assets open-end fund has to worry about
that it's really up to the fund manager
to decide when they do things like a
dividend at a time that is right for
them so there's a little bit more
flexibility right over here